so this is item 71 on the checklist it's
the first one we're going to go over
today which is you want to check this
box are you a delaware square you need
to be a delaware c corp if you're going
to raise money from investors in america
why
well delaware law is very favorable to
shareholders and to companies this means
the company must do what is best for all
the shareholders in the company and this
is why venture capitalists
and founders and everybody involved in
entrepreneurship has really
selected this as the winning type of
corporation there are other ones out
there that might be better for crypto or
might be better for hedge funds there
are offshore types
but for whatever reason
this type of company uh has become the
standard here in america
and even if you're an australian company
or uk company you can be a delaware
corporation so that people can invest in
your company easily
once you say you're a canadian company a
european country you know or a company
in a specific european country
tax
uh lawsuits
investor rights going public tax
treatment i already mentioned i think
accounting practices all of that and hr
issues all will change
if you're investing and you're trying to
scale an industry
you really want to be comfortable and
understand
one of these jurisdictions and that one
is the delaware c corp investors are
very comfortable about it they know it
the process is super
straightforward and there's very limited
liability there are some tax benefits
if you're an international company
looking to raise from us vcs but you
don't have a u.s entity well you
probably should just create a us entity
you can talk to your attorneys about
that some people flip it over but it is
absolutely correct uh to do a delaware c
corp now some people say hey what about
an llc one times tax treatment the
problem with that is
if you're going to take investors and
you start as an llc you're going to have
to switch over to a c corp and when you
do switch over to a c corp a delaware c
uh it's gonna just
be like paying your legal bills over
again and you have accounting issues
llcs are great for venture funds or
partnerships like a law partnership or
an accounting partnership with a bunch
of cpas or maybe you're buying real
estate assets because it has one time
taxation
and that's great but you don't have
shares in an llc
you have units and it's a completely
different structure they're for two
different types of entities so you can
talk to your lawyer about that you can
do some google searches but just for the
purposes of this checklist we don't
really need to debate it you need to be
a delaware c and you again when you're
raising from venture capitalists you
don't want to throw up red flags
having the wrong incorporation is like
walking into the room holding like five
red flags in each hand that you don't
know what you're doing
okay
item 72
do you have a cap table and is it clean
a messy cap table is a deal killer it is
a huge red flag for investors and it
often results in people not investing in
a company when they say the cap table is
broken or a messy cap table it means
that there are some people early on in
the cap table that have a very large
percentage of the company and maybe they
got it at a very low price and then the
founders ownership is way below 50
before they get to series a
when you're at a series a you really
want the founders to be above 50 percent
you have two founders 25 percent each of
three founders 15 to 18 each maybe even
20 percent each why does it need to be
there well we anticipate there'll be a
series b and people will be diluted 15
20 percent there'll be a series c maybe
you've diluted 10 to 15 percent and then
you do another round of funding and you
diluted another 10 you get the idea
you get diluted a couple of times you
might be down if you're a solo founder
at 20 by the time the company gets sold
or if you're two founders you might wind
up with seven eight nine percent of the
company when it goes public
that seems fine it seems fair you have
all this money put in the employees got
10 15 percent a bunch of investors got
the the bulk of the company they put a
ton of money to work
and uh maybe you sold some secondary
shares along the way but it needs to be
clean at the start and so pre-series a
founder is going to need to own 50 to 65
that's series a maybe they get cut to 40
50 like i was saying series b 30 40
series c 20 to 30 ipo exit 10 to 20
ownership
you don't want to give a large
percentage of your company to a dev shop
or consulting firm there are predatory
accelerators and dev shops and
consultants who will say hey
uh we'll give you 10k plus we'll build
your app which will cost five hundred
thousand dollars it'll take us six
months and uh we value your company at
two million so we now own
for the 100k
we own five percent and for the 500k we
own another 25 now they own 30 of your
company and now you're going into an
accelerator they get seven percent now
37 is owned by investors and then a seed
round happens you dilute 20
oh my god you know you're way behind the
numbers i just stated
so
uh we see this all the time it can be
fixed it's just painful so one of the
things that happens all the time is a
company that's done too much fundraising
will get to a new fundraising round and
the investor will say listen i will give
you 10 million dollars for your series a
for 25 of the company but the founders
are only at 30 i want to see them at 50
so therefore i want to do a founder
refresh and that's not coming out of my
25 that's coming out of everybody else's
and so boom now all your previous
investors get diluted they all feel
terrible about it
how do you mitigate against them feeling
terrible about it well
if they can participate in the new round
well then they can at least buy more
shares and keep their percentage
ownership up
aka pro rata and um another way to do it
is to just be fair with them maybe put
that additional founder grant at five
years maybe they you know the founders
each get two percent a year for five
years one percent a year for five years
that's i've seen five percent
one percent uh each year for five years
basically locks in the founders if
they've been toiling away for three or
four years and they're fully invested
you might have to do that anyway
but this can create a lot of bad
feelings and sometimes a venture capital
firm i've seen this three or four times
recently a venture capital firm will say
to win a deal we'll give the founders a
25
founder refresh and we want these terms
and the founder says oh this is the best
deal we could find i couldn't get
anybody else over the finish line and
now you got this inside dealing is it
illegal is it unethical
was that the best deal well the fact
that we have to sit here and debate it
is what creates all the bad feelings
because i've had a situation recently i
would say what company i'll make this a
little bit mysterious by blending the
numbers here
but i had a company that couldn't raise
around except with this one predatory
jerk ceo of vc who wanted to give them a
whole bunch of equity the i got the
internal folks to make another offer and
they didn't take the internal offer they
still wanted to go with that one so then
it was like okay the founder is really
just looking out for themselves and we
don't need to be involved with this
company anymore we're gonna basically
you know
not participate as much as we would
because the founders kind of screwed us
right and that's the bad feelings that
you don't want to have with your
investors so you have to be very careful
about this stuff it is a little dicey
communicating well and being reasonable
is the way to avoid this
but sometimes you get predatory vcs jerk
vcs who will just put in these like take
or leave it offers then it's up to the
existing investors to give an offer
that is reasonable to the founder and
you know then the founder has to want to
take it and
none of this is easy because the founder
could quit the vc could pull its term
sheet the existing investors can sue all
kinds of bad things that happen and
that's actually kind of the great part
about equity structures is because
everybody's tied to that share price and
the number of shares they have this kind
of debate can happen
if you listen to this week in startups
often you've heard me talk about oh do
suite of business apps a lot well
they're gonna give you your first app
free forever and then a thousand dollars
off your implementation pack at odoo.com
twist odo dot com twist and here's why
odoo is so great for startups well their
suite of business apps can help you run
your entire company from just one
platform they're gonna streamline all
your workflows by bringing all your
information together this eliminates all
the annoying repetitive tests like
entering data across multiple platforms
plus if you only need two or three apps
right now that's okay use those two or
three apps to optimize your workflow and
that's all you'll pay for odoo is not
going to charge you for apps you don't
use of course they wouldn't do that so
odoo offers 30 main apps and over 16 000
apps from their open source community
you know the apps they have bookkeeping
sales crm website builders and more
again your first app is free forever and
odu is offering a thousand dollar credit
on your first implementation pack
go to odoo.com twist for a thousand
dollars off that's odo.com
twist